[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So, your shiny new
app is ready to be
submitted to the App Store.
You've gone through the
long and tiresome process
of feature definition, design,
implementation, and of course,
testing, Because you know
your potential users deserve
the best possible
experience using your app.
Yep, you're good to go.
Or are you?
There's one type of test
that is too often overlooked,
but shouldn't be, especially
if you're aiming at users
from developing markets.
When you're working
on your app, you're
probably using your
home or office Wi-Fi.
Or, since you're familiar
with the importance of testing
your app in various
network conditions,
you're also testing it with
your carrier's high speed
mobile network.
Either way, at least
some of your users
are bound to be using your
app in a significantly
worse network environment.
The last thing you want
is for one of your users
to be the first to test your
app in a poor network condition.
If a user using your
app will attempt
to use it in a low
connectivity environment,
bad things may happen.
What can possibly
go wrong, you ask?
Well, your requests
may time out.
Responses may get lost.
You may encounter
race conditions
you've never considered before.
Your UI may get stuck.
And your user may be not so
forgiving for the bad user
experience your app provides.
Since we all want our
users to have the best
possible experience
using our apps,
it's worthwhile to put
effort into simulating
these difficult situations
to make sure we're
doing the best we can.
Once we put ourselves
in our users' shoes,
we can take actions to
improve these use cases.
Apple offers a great tool for
testing apps in varying network
conditions.
It's called Network
Link Conditioner,
and if it's not part of your
regular testing routine,
it definitely should be.
You can use this tool to
simulate various network
conditions in a simple way.
On your iOS device, go
to Settings, Developer,
and press the Status Row on
the Network Link Conditioner
section.
There, you'll see a list of
all the existing presets.
You can see a detailed
description of each of them
by selecting the relevant row.
If you don't find exactly
what you're looking for,
or you have a specific
scenario you'd like to test,
you can set up a
new configuration
with specific values
for each of the fields.
Once you've selected
the relevant option,
don't forget to turn on the
Enable switch on the top row
to really simulate
that condition.
Otherwise things may look
like they're running smoothly
when they're really not.
Also very important,
don't forget
to turn off this option
when you're done testing.
Let's look at some
examples for major issues
that can be prevented by testing
your app in non-ideal network
conditions.
Let's say your app
is a game that can be
played on various platforms--
iOS, Android, and web.
And your app loads the
user updated game score
from the server in
every app launch,
since it may have changed
since the user last
played the app on this device.
Since it's a very small
piece of information
and since it's always fetched
from the server on app launch,
without thinking
too much about it,
you made this fetch synchronous.
Which, of course, is
something you should never do.
Everything looks great
when you test your app
on your Wi-Fi or even your
high speed mobile connection.
But when you test it on a very
poor connection using Network
Link Conditioner, you
notice that the UI
becomes unresponsive
from the time
the request for the updated
score is sent to the server
until the response is
returned to the app.
You didn't notice
this delay when
you were using your high
speed network connection.
But now that it's a
few seconds or worse,
it's hard not to notice it.
Good thing you tested
your app properly
instead of having one of
your unfortunate users
encounter this bug.
So you change your
score fetching logic
to work asynchronously, as it
should, and run the test again.
It takes the score some
time to be displayed--
the same few seconds delay you
saw when the display got stuck
before--
but the user can use the
app freely during this time.
You move on to checking
the user profile screen.
But unfortunately you
see a blank screen.
You wait a little for the
screen's display to update,
but nothing changes.
It turns out that
the request timed out
and there is no retry
mechanism or an indication
to the users, who
may find themselves
staring at a blank screen
without knowing why.
By supporting some kind
of retry mechanism,
you can make sure
that the page loads
in the event that the user is in
an area with poor connectivity,
or at least display an
appropriate error message.
These were just two
relatively simple examples
of things that can go wrong when
using poor network conditions.
Notice that the same
problematic scenarios
can be encountered when your
server is heavily overloaded.
If your timeout is
set to 30 seconds
and the server only
starts handling requests
after 40 seconds, the
same issues will occur.
So it's definitely
worth testing.
I hope you found this
short tip helpful
and will include it in
your testing routine.
I'm Rony Rozen, for Route
85, thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]